[Music]
[Music]
welcome back and happy new year hot ones
fans this is sean evans checking in to
say that i have missed you
i've missed you so so much and looking
forward to this new year coming off the
one that we just had
i know that only one thing is
predictable that it'll be unpredictable
but here in season 14 i'm hoping it's
our return to normalcy
i'm hoping that it's the light at the
end of the tunnel and here at hot ones
there is no tradition more important
more sacred than the unveiling of the
new season lineup
it's here it's finally here and it's as
heartwarming as it is terrifying
and for season 14 we're cranking the
knobs here as we continue our 200-plus
episode experiment to see how hot is too
hot for celebrities who are just trying
to make it through a press run
and to kick off the year we have a mix
of old and new some fresh faces here in
the front half of the lineup and then
some of our favorite makers
hellfire torchbearer as the scovilles
climb and climb and climb so
pray silence please it is time for the
season 14
hot ones hot sauce reveal and to kick
things off in the lead-off spot after
garlic fresno's day in the sun it's
returned to the classic classic
if i had a bitcoin for every time the
classic made someone say
hmm this is tasty i think i can do this
i would almost certainly be a
millionaire on paper by now so here it
is
the classic classic back in the one spot
and it feels so right
okay moving on to number two hot and
saucy
this sauce right here we welcome it to
the table it's the handiwork of jamaican
american chef sam davis elance
right up town in harlem this one
combines italian pepperoncini with
garlic and honey for a tangy sauce that
somehow feels
extremely new york this sauce right here
it's perfect
for a slice folded eating it while you
walk down the street
and we go from number two to three from
the city
to a beach vacation courtesy of mark's
barbados style hot sauce
longtime hot ones viewers know that i
have a soft spot for caribbean hot
sauces
i like the mustard i like the scotch
bonnets and i don't have any hard date
on hand but i'd venture to say that if
you look back in the last 13 plus
seasons
this style of hot sauce also some of the
most popular with our guests
so we have an island vacation pineapples
mango a little kiss of rum but after the
three spot the vacation ends
because we have carolina reapers lurking
as we move on to number four
this is hellfire's devil's blend
hellfire's fear this sauce used to be a
number nine in the lineup but this one
dials down the heat and dials up the
flavor with fire roasted jalapenos
tomatillo granny smith apples and
scallion
as our friend lil yachty would say
that's the devil's snack
all right moving on to number five it's
a familiar one los calientes rojo you
know los calientes rojo it's just like
los calientes
but red los calientes rojo enough flavor
to be familiar but enough heat to give
guests a taste of what's to come and
that my friends is what makes los
calientes the perfect halfway mark the
perfect turning point sauce the perfect
sauce
for explain that gram and as we move on
to number six og fans of the show
i know you've been eyeing it it's a name
that you might recognize from season two
and the number six spot leading off the
back half
high river sauces
this sauce is the brainchild of steve
seaberry the same dude who founded the
event i missed most in 2020 the new york
city hot sauce expo
shout out to my guide chip hearn hope
you're doing good buddy
the poetically named tears of the sun
private reserve combines peach goes
scorpion and habanero
with papaya and peaches it creates this
epic tug of war between the sweet and
the heat
and moving on to number seven all right
if you're somebody who likes chicken
tenders with honey mustard
our friends at torch bear they have made
the ultimate hot sauce for you
honey badger is silky smooth but
deceptively easy to eat
conjuring up childhood memories with the
honey mustard flavor
and then turning them into nightmares
with handfuls of scorpion and reaper
peppers
that is the formula of our number seven
sauce
shout out to honey badgers shout out to
randall
and shout out to mr steady here in the
eight spot
to bomb beyond insanity the people's
champ
a sauce were for whatever reason more
loyalty than anything we make
it is here it stays the bomb beyond
insanity in the eight spot
and then let me pull back the curtain
for you guys tell you what's kind of
complicated when you're making a hot
ones hot sauce lineup that features the
bomb
once guests have to bomb their mouths go
numb they're disoriented
it's hard to have a neck sauce it's hard
to keep
inching it up because people are so
flamed out last season
we went hot to hot to hot to close it
out
and this season i think we went hotter
for those who watched hot ones the game
show you'll remember eye of the scorpion
is the sauce that was smoking out teams
in the pepperdome
and as the name suggests it's pretty
much just pure scorpion pepper with some
scorpion powder
thrown in for good measure there are no
prizes for our guests other than pride
and giving the internet what it wants
and in this year's lineup to close it
out i think above
all other lineups it really does
challenge people to close things out
to bomb to eye of the scorpion and then
of course
it's the gold bottle baby the last dab
apollo
rides again for the fans who complained
triple x it's not hot enough you win and
you're welcome
for the guests on the show i am so so
sorry
and there you have it it's the hot ones
season 14
lineup the 10 bottles the playing cards
they're here and
as you know as always with a hot sauce
reveal that means the premiere is right
around the corner
and hot ones returns january
28th that's right january 28th
we are back and as a reminder first we
feast in hot ones are working with
common threads to help them in their
mission of providing meals and culinary
education to under-resourced communities
across the us
you guys absolutely blew us away
seventeen thousand dollars raised on the
last video
if you can if you're able let's keep
that energy going in 2021
thank you so much for watching i have
missed you
so much hot ones rides again january
28th
we'll see you then
[Music]
have you heard the news hot one's not
good honey it's honey infused with
pepper x
the best of two worlds everybody honey
now
nugget nugget honey honey honey
honey nugget nugget honey honey
hot ones nugget honey get yours today
and see what all the buzz is about
only at heatness.com
[Music]
to be no to be
or not to be now on heatness.com
it's how
oh i'm a bee